a relationship meltdown a new tattoo and
an ex hit with criminal charges here's
what really happened to brandy passante
from storage wars
interesting is one way to put it
fame was a surprise to brandy and jared
back when storage wars debuted in 2010.
they weren't expecting their appearances
on the show to go anywhere but when they
did brandi and jared weren't ready for
any of it randy went from full-time mom
and part-time worker to clocking 60
hours a week on the job the commitment
also made her miss out on important
family events like her daughter's first
day of kindergarten because of that she
took a temporary leave of absence from
the show in 2014 with jared in tow
suddenly spending every waking minute
together for the show brandy and jared's
personality started to collide like
never before at the time they were also
co-managing their now and then thrift
store in orange california which wasn't
making anything easier brandy explained
to the time standard working together as
a couple every day is quite an obstacle
to overcome we're together 24 hours a
day seven days a week trying to make
business decisions together what was i
thinking as fans witnessed on the show
the pair were often at each other's
throats but things were apparently even
worse off screen as jared admitted to
the oc register it makes our dysfunction
seem a little less dysfunctional
leveraging off their successful brand
the couple soon landed their very own
spin-off show randy and jared married to
the job the series followed the parish
journey as business owners partners and
parents at one point the couple even
seemed to be headed to the altar but
they never actually ended up tying the
knot i mean after 15 years of being with
jared i mean i just assumed that that
ship had sailed unfortunately for the
duo the show failed to garner the same
buzz that storage wars did a e pulled
the plug on the show after just eight
episodes
brandi and jared's relationship was over
long before they went public with it in
2021 but it was clear they were on thin
ice back in 2018
jared's absence from brandy's instagram
was obvious to eagle-eyed fans as well
as the media some outlets even spotted
the star without her engagement ring and
cited a few photo ops with new guys not
to be left in the dust jared also went
public with girlfriend rachelle beckman
given the overwhelming evidence of
trouble between the two no one was truly
surprised when brandy finally broke the
news that it was over
season 13 of storage wars brought about
one of the show's biggest switch-ups the
couple formerly known as the young guns
would no longer be working as a team if
anyone thought that meant less drama
they were wrong as jared didn't hesitate
to make things personal brandy bids on
it i'll probably bet during the run up
to the season 13 premiere randy posted a
promo shot on twitter in which jared's
face was fully covered with a devil
emoji i could watch this all day long
for brandy the drama on the show was one
thing in real life however when jared
showed up at a gathering he wasn't
invited to things got physical when he
allegedly shoved brandy multiple times
brandy would go on to claim that similar
incidents contributed to the end of
their decades-long relationship in her
efforts to move forward she even got a
tattoo to symbolize her journey toward
independence jared denied the
allegations but was charged with
domestic battery according to tmz a e
launched an investigation into the
matter and while the findings were never
revealed jared was nowhere to be seen on
the show's 14th season the breakup left
brandy with deep psychological wounds
and she had trouble cultivating her own
identity as a single woman however after
nearly a decade spent living as one half
of a pair brandy is finally taking
control of her own destiny the star
addressed rumors about her relationship
status in february of 2021 and while she
admitted that she's dated a little she's
currently thriving on her own
after the split brandy got primary
custody of the couple's two teens peyton
and cameron while raising them alone
might seem like a big task the star has
admitted that she has been pretty much
doing it herself even when jared was in
the picture as for how she's perfected
her work-life balance she told
mylifetime.com i used to be a
stay-at-home mom and it was very
difficult for me i love my kids but i
felt alienated and depressed when i
didn't have a career so i think i'm a
better parent because i work i'm happier
because of it my mom wants you to shut
your face that's my son cameron even
though she's always glammed up for the
cameras herself brandi has dutifully
protected her kids privacy when they
were younger they were never seen on
social media now that they've grown up
brandi is happy to share the occasional
peek into her family life
storage wars may have netted brandy an
estimated 2 million fortune but the
reality star is happy to give back to
those in need these days she's
advocating for women who have also faced
domestic violence brandy works closely
with the women's own worth organization
as the host of their annual wow apaluza
event in 2019
she helped the charity bring in roughly
100 000 in donations brandi finds her
charity work extremely rewarding as she
told the sailing courier i have
experienced some things in my life and
it's a really wonderful cause i wanted
to help in any way possible check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite reality stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one